so the next part of this that I think is
particularly interesting and this is
really where we met because of the
Twitter thing that I referenced earlier
is there has been sort of an endless
onslaught on Sam Harris since this now
Sam is a philosopher I think he's a
neuroscientist I read some of his books
he's not a political person per se he
writes a little bit about politics but
not really but there has been this
endless onslaught and I think slandering
and smearing him coming from the left
from people that in some cases I admire
partly some people that I've worked with
I'm talking about from from Glenn
Greenwald who obviously has done great
stuff with the NSA and Reza asked on my
former boss Jiang Kyogre people that are
really distorting his views and I wanted
to show a tweet that I got last night
that I think kind of sums up the whole
thing so let's take a look at the tweet
okay so this had nothing I was
entreating about this this has nothing
to do with anything
then someone tweet does have any
question for Rubin report how it exactly
are we better than Isis if we nuke the
Middle East killing millions of
civilians like Sam Harris suggests and
then Sam Harris later wrote back the
person and said you really believe that
I've actually suggested that okay so
that tweet right there the reason I
wanted to use it is because I feel like
it's a perfect example of how this
discussion that we're talking about has
been so far derailed now of course Sam
Harris doesn't want a new climate the
Middle East
he had one page in his book that's
mostly about philosophy and religion
where he's talking about how in the Cold
War we had you know mutual assurances
basically with Russia because you had
rational actors basically that wouldn't
nuke each other because then they were
afraid they were gonna get new now this
is nothing to he never said nuke the
Middle East or any of this stuff but
these people keep implying it they keep
retweeting memes of you know selective
quotes what do you make of that I mean
these these are pretty respected people
some that I know personally which is why
I struggle with this so much
you know in the battle of ideologies the
people that you want to go after or not
the people who've got big muscles but
the people have big brains those are so
totalitarian ideologies always go after
the intellectuals first they want to
purge them because they don't want
anybody to counter their narrative and
so this is exactly what happens to guys
like sam Harris he has a huge following
that he can't be literally beheaded
because we don't live in the Middle East
but I could certainly try my darkness to
behead his reputation and I'm going to
do that by engaging in endless
formation so that people can distance
himself from him and he's just a quack
he's a he's a war monger he's a Nazi
he's part of a Zionist conspiracy and
hopefully okay and don't forget me okay
right that's a neocon is part of
Halliburton yeah and so on and and and
the way I behead him the way I silenced
him is by smearing him right so isn't
that really the crazy part of this when
when they're saying well you know Sam
Harris is in the same neocon group or
Bill Maher's in the same neocon group as
Dick Cheney Bill Maher has never no more
talked about all the time he wants our
we have 30,000 traps or something in
Germany what the hell are they doing
there man this is literally the reverse
of a neocon but these these slurs these
are slanders right really I mean is that
well these these false equivalences you
are everywhere within this discourse so
for example if you take some feminists
they'll argue that the bikini is a
patriarchal tool of oppression whereas
the burka is a liberating thing because
it removes the male gaze from the
picture right so while the bikini clad
woman is being visually raped by men
once you once you Don the burqa she is
liberated so these types of equivalences
are astonishing but they're everywhere
right now as backwards as I may think
that is I would say you know what you
can believe that if you want but it
should be up to the woman to decide
where in most of those countries where
women are wearing burkas they don't
really have the choice not to wear of
course